Can you please clarify what trophoblasts are and how enzymes and or products like
protocell killed trophoblasts? Thank you very much.
So trophoblasts are, okay, so this gets a little complicated because trophoblasts are
what technically a trophoblast is an embryonic term embryonic term that when an egg is fertilized
by a sperm, it goes through a stage that is called the trophoblasts and that's what attaches
to the uterus wall is that trophoblast. That's what a trophoblast is in anatomical terms, but what this
person is talking about is a trophoblast was a term that was used by Dr. William Kelly when he
was describing what he thought were pre-cancerous cells. So these were cells that were immature, so
trophoblast comes from the Latin term trophoblast, which means to adhere to and blasts, which means
immature cells. So we've talked a lot about what you're especially talking about leukemia, the blood
cancers, you end up with a lot of blast cells and those are immature white blood cells. So in the
leukemia, you're making all these immature white blood cells that are not maturing and that they don't
act like mature white blood cells, doing what mature white blood cells are going to are supposed to
do and that's what can kill you. You have no immune system left, that's a mature immune system.
That's what leukemia is. Well, trophoblasts were was a term that was used to describe immature
cancer cells that that is what we need to kill as these trophoblasts and that's what cancer really
is. That has not been a proven theory. It's all theoretically out there in the alternative cancer
world, though these terms have not been used for decades. So when with Dr. William Kelly's work with
enzymes and that's the talk about killing these trophoblasts. So but really how enzyme theory works,
when you're taking high dose pancreatic enzymes, you're really not killing the cancer. You're really
killing and you're really breaking down the acidic slime layer around a cancer so that your immune
system can kill the cancer. Enzymes do not kill cells. So you're not it was that was the theory
back then, but that's been proven to be false. Though you can't argue with it. How does enzyme therapy
work then? Well, enzyme therapy works. And this is just my opinion because it's breaking down the
acidic layer that's created with a when cells are in rapid replication. There's a lot of waste that's
being spilled out into the extracellular space. That's the space between the cells. And that
actually gives the cancer cell even more ability to continue to grow and abated because it makes it
that that extra waste makes it difficult for your immune system to get at the cancer to kill
those cells. So enzyme therapy can help break down that waste and leave them exposed, leave your
cancer cells exposed. That's really what so if you search for a trophoblast, I don't know what you'd
find, but I think it would bring you to some embryonic description of what a trophoblast is
in embryonic terminology.